[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Maria
oui oui oui oui oui
[Musique]
oui tout le long de la rivière Rin cambR
la mine fière posé sur sa tête alière
elle portait son potolet tout le long de
la rivière rincambr la mine fière dans
la brise printanière vers la V salad ta
silhouette dégère au jupon de couleur
claire mais dans l'eau une lumière qui
va comme un feu folet ta silhouette lère
j au milieu des lavandières BO jolis ref
Maria Maria dis tout jeach des ufs pour
le prix de mon lait avec les poussins
j'aurai de beau poulets avec les poulets
j'achète un cochon tous les gens diront
Mar Mar avec le cochon c'est payé V et
vach sielle les revend mon Dieu qu'elle
V trop qu'elle V TR si Paris çaourche
oui tout le long de la rivière
le FUS bandouère bouchant de la clairère
est venu le beau
[Musique]
prois Mo je t'espère depuis des mois tu
m ch te mets pas en colère mon âme est
un
braséis jeesp depis des mois
et devant le
CAL comme ça tu sais je vendre Mon' pas
le temp je connais ton couplé je pars à
la ville acheter mon trousseau il est à
Moroso Maria Maria tous les chemins
mènent à Rome l'éclat de tes yeux fait t
beau trousseau et bien l'homme qui sera
ton homme oui
oui tout le long de la rivière j'ai vu
flotter ta crinière et caché dans les
Fougières je t regardais passer le long
de la rivière j'ai vu flotter ta
crinière je risquerais les galères pour
un seul de tes baiser sinon mes bras je
te s je te garde prisonnière tu me
trouves téméraire ma foi je le suis
assez si dans mes bras je te s je te
garde prisonnière
risquer j'ai envie de t'emer
[Musique]
Mar tout va je t'en prie je t'aime mais
laisse-moi tu vois que je tremble tu
vois mon émoi alors peddro dans ses bras
laassés et toutour d'elle bientôt tout
tourné la terre et le ciel dans les yeux
du garçon le ruissau ses pensées son
troupau sa maison Mar Maré s'est envolé
par-dessus les moulins dans ses bras
câin adieu pour vach et cochons et
couver mais c'est un grand amour qu'elle
vient de trouver
[Musique]
a